Traduttore: Valentina Maggio
Revisore: Federico Sangati
Qualche volta torna sul comodino
quel libro che contiene quella frase
che ha cambiato in maniera importante
il mio modo di lavorare.
Non si tratta solo
di progettare tecnologie,
bisogna essere consci
che quelle tecnologie cambieranno la vita
delle persone a cui sono destinate.
Anche se le persone non le useranno,
paradossalmente, perché forse
saranno arrabbiate
o frustrate da una tecnologia
che magari gli è stata imposta.
Durante i miei studi in ingegneria
stavo frequentando il corso
di ingegneria del software
e alla prima lezione il docente, entrando,
disse con la sua prima slide:
"Il 90% degli investimenti
che si fanno in tecnologia,
in particolare in tecnologia informatica,
non portano spesso ai frutti desiderati."
Non andiamo a sindacare
sul 90% piuttosto che il 92;
questo numero, evidentemente,
un po' alla volta si abbassa,
ma mi dicono che non sia
ancora sceso sotto l'80%.
Ero al terzo anno, avevo due scelte:
la prima era quella di lasciar perdere,
cambiare lavoro.
La seconda, invece,
quella di rendersi conto che forse
c'era tanto da fare.
Ho deciso di andare fino in fondo
su questa faccenda
della difficoltàdi portare
la tecnologia alle persone
perché ne migliori la qualità della vita.
A quei tempi assistevamo all'avvento
della programmazione
orientata agli oggetti.
La programmazione orientata
agli oggetti aveva,
questa almeno è stata la mia
interpretazione tra le tante valenze,
la possibilità di aiutare noi tecnici
a sviluppare delle tecnologie
più malleabili rispetto a quelle
che si sviluppavano prima.
La malleabilità delle tecnologie
ha un impatto importante
quando le si porta
nei contesti lavorativi,
perché la tecnologia, un po' come
un virus, cambia un organismo,
quindi cambia un'organizzazione.
Allora è complicato
approcciare facendo
l'analisi dei problemi inizialmente,
interpretando e progettando una soluzione.
Perché i giochi cominciano nel momento
in cui la tecnologia entra in uso.
Quello è il momento in cui le persone
danno senso alla tecnologia.
Da quell'esperienza 10 anni fa
mi ero portato via
sicuramente la valenza
dell'object oriented
per creare tecnologie più flessibili.
Però mi ero anche portato via
che forse ciò non bastava.
Qualche anno dopo, infatti,
ragionammo e pubblicammo
un articolo dedicato
alla progettazione delle tecnologie
che potessero essere ridefinite in uso
direttamente da parte di
coloro che le usano.
Era il 2002.
A dir la verità questo rimase
un'intuizione per parecchi mesi,
parecchi anni, direi.
Abbiamo dovuto aspettare
l'avvento di queste tecnologie,
per cominciare a capire che
quell'intuizione era interessante.
Perché queste sono effettivamente
tecnologie che le persone
possono ridefinire in uso mentre le usano.
Ed evidentemente questo è un processo.
Il divertimento di trovare
delle funzionalità
che non c'erano ieri ma che ci sono oggi
e di poterle portare
su questi dispositivi,
fa parte di quella che è
l'esperienza delle persone
quando utilizzano la tecnologia.
E di sicuro queste tecnologie
sono tra quelle che
hanno impattato più di altre
sulla qualità della nostra vita.
Non c'è, penso, ombra di dubbio.
Quindi, avere tecnologie malleabili,
provare a mettere nelle mani delle persone
la possibilità di riconfigurare
queste tecnologie.
E allora è venuta la voglia di chiedersi:
"Cos'altro si può fare, per migliorare
il fatto che le persone comprendano
cioè portino dentro di sé la tecnologia?"
Il terzo passaggio su cui sto lavorando,
ed è un lavoro lungo,
è quello di provare a far coincidere
gli utenti delle tecnologie
con chi le progetta.
Io penso che molto dell'insuccesso
legato all'introduzione delle tecnologie
nei contesti di lavoro
e di vita delle persone,
sia legato al fatto che,
spesso, chi le progetta
non coincide con chi le usa.
E il fatto di comprendere, da tecnico,
il contesto di vita
e di lavoro degli altri
è un lavoro che, anche
sforzandosi con empatia,
è una cosa molto complicata da fare.
Addirittura i filosofi dicono che
non si può fare, è inaccessibile
la conoscenza che sta nei contesti
di vita e di lavoro degli altri.
Anche se ci si sforza
di guardarli con occhi diversi,
lì si va a impattare su un mondo
che non ci appartiene, come tecnici.
Devo aggiungere anche il fatto che
la comprensione porta dentro una cosa
nuova che cambia il contesto.
Quindi, è una comprensione
che diventa piena e rotonda
nella misura in cui effettivamente
quel contesto si riesce a viverlo.
I miei colleghi che
ogni tanto mi prendono in giro
quando sentono che
sono particolarmente attaccato
alle vicende di Apple mi dicono:
"Ma sei un apple fan!"
Ma non si tratta tanto
di essere un apple fan;
è che quel mondo è fatto di persone
dove chi fa le tecnologie
spesso coincide con chi le usa.
Il mondo degli sviluppatori delle app:
se andiamo a vedere
le app di maggior successo,
troviamo quasi sempre
una corrispondenza importante
tra chi quelle tecnologie le fa e che
poi ne diventa anche il primo utente.
Questa per me è una cosa cosmica;
una cosa che mi incuriosisce tantissimo.
Il terzo tassello, questo dell'avvicinare
le persone alla progettazione
ha a che fare con un'esperienza
di progetto vissuta 7-8 anni fa,
di cui gli effetti sono tuttora in campo,
li vivo tuttora sulla mia pelle.
Certe cose le ho capite molto tardi.
Dovevo affrontare una consulenza
in un'azienda particolarmente complessa
e mi ero portato,
per prendere degli appunti,
questa tecnologia meravigliosa
che vedete alle mie spalle.
Io pensavo di utilizzarli per velocizzare
appunto la presa delle note,
ma all'improvviso queste tecnologie
sono finite nelle mani delle persone
che avevo con me
e che stavo per aiutare.
Era una consulenza di tipo tradizionale
e all'improvviso: "Boom!"
Mi son trovato catapultato completamente
fuori da questa esperienza
mentre li vedevo a loro agio
utilizzare questi materiali
chiaramente accessibili per loro;
si tratta di materiali semplici,
la carta, i post-it
e alcuni elementi di interfaccia,
e mi sono meravigliato di quanta energia,
di quanta creatività
sia venuta fuori
da quel contesto di lavoro.
Ragionandoci poi dopo,
mi sono anche reso conto
che mai avrei potuto
portare via così tanto da loro,
anche in termini di relazione umana,
se non li avessi messi nella condizione
di cambiare le loro prospettive,
anche cambiare la loro
comprensione del problema
per avvicinarsi un po' alla volta
da soli alle possibili soluzioni.
Soluzioni che non sono
di natura tecnologica,
soluzioni che, questo è il valore
più importante,
includono loro, come utenti.
Soluzioni, dove loro per primi
possono sperimentare,
ma non sperimentano la tecnologia,
sperimentano quelle che sono
le loro pratiche di lavoro nuove
per via della tecnologia.
Evidentemente sono tutti concentrati
sulle nuove pratiche di lavoro;
di tecnologia non parlano.
Semplicemente sanno che, prima o poi,
la potranno avere
a disposizione per utilizzarla.
È qui il nodo centrale
di quello che sto facendo
in questo momento nella vita.
Qui si ridefinisce il concetto
di design, di progettazione.
È una progettazione che non porta più
soluzioni con la pretesa che siano giuste,
ma è una progettazione
che porta un linguaggio
e protegge uno spazio di lavoro
all'interno del quale i destinatari,
quindi gli esperti,
quelli che hanno la vera conoscenza
di un contesto di lavoro,
possono lavorare per innovare.
Voglio farvi sentire, per ultima cosa,
una brevissima intervista
che ho fatto qualche tempo fa
ad un gruppo di queste persone
che sono diventate designer
dell'innovazione
nella propria realtà aziendale
e che ancora oggi
portano avanti il progetto.
L'aspetto più importante
di questo laboratorio
è la possibilità di lavorare assieme
in un gruppo di lavoro
che non si costituisce normalmente
nel lavoro di tutti i giorni
e quindi di mettere in comune
esperienza diverse, approcci diversi,
problemi differenti.
Il fatto di lavorare assieme,
prenderci del tempo per scambiare le idee,
perché appunto tante volte le idee,
cioè ognuno ha le proprie idee...
Mi sentivo portato e interessato per
le funzioni di cui mi occupo in APT,
soprattutto al linguaggio web.
Però mi sono accorto che
partecipare a questo corso significa
rimettere in discussione,
ripensare radicalmente
l'organizzazione del lavoro nostro
e vedere anche sotto una nuova luce....
Ok!
Quando oggi mi chiedono
di parlare di tecnologie,
dico sempre provocatoriamente:
"La tecnologia non esiste.
Esiste quello che provano le persone
quando la usano, la tecnologia."
La mia storia mi sta spostando da
essere progettista di tecnologie
ad essere progettista
della comprensione delle tecnologie.
Io penso che avere le persone
e la loro energia,
le loro intelligenze
in un contesto di progettazione,
che è anche un processo
di apprendimento per loro,
sia una cosa fondamentale oggi,
per avere successo nel realizzare qualcosa
che impatti nella qualità della vita.
Questo ridefinisce in maniera importante
anche il ruolo dell'esperto
delle tecnologie
che non fa solo
lo human computer interaction,
ma fa lo human to human
interaction molto spesso.
Queste esperienze progettuali
hanno radicalmente cambiato
il nostro sguardo al design.
Abbiamo lavorato per una decina di anni
su più di 100 progetti con questi approcci
e abbiamo costruito un gruppo di persone,
alcune di queste sono
in questa sala e le ringrazio,
che tutti i giorni portano avanti
questa visione dell'innovazione
dedicandovisi.
Grazie!